hello and welcome to the active
inference live stream today is active
inference live stream 16.2
on february 23rd 2021.
welcome to the active inference lab
everyone we're a participatory online
lab that is communicating learning and
practicing applied active inference you
can find us on our website twitter email
youtube
discord key based teams
this is recorded and an archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so that we can be improving on
our work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome and as far as the netiquette the
video etiquette for the live streams
we'll be muting raising our hand writing
down our points using respectful speech
behavior
today in 16.2 at the end of february
we are having a follow-up discussion on
the paper of wanja visa and carl fristen
neural correlates of consciousness and
last week we were really um it was
really special to have laundry come on
the stream and quite interesting stuff
and next week we're going to be having
our first ever quarterly round table
which will be providing some updates on
the different projects of the active
inference lab
also as far as upcoming streams and
events
we have a new i guess uh series called
the guest stream so this is the live
stream which is the participatory group
discussion we have the model stream
which is the walkthrough or a tutorial
of a more technical piece and then the
guest stream is going to be kind of like
anything goes just anytime somebody has
a new paper out
or they want to be raising some topic to
visibility we want to be there for them
and help them on that so tomorrow we're
going to be having majeed benny speak on
his recent paper a critical analysis of
markovian monism and then in march and
in may we'll have guest visits from
demetrius bolas and anna siaunica
and if you have a suggestion for any of
these other events
or you want to be featured on an event
or you'd like to co-organize an event
with us then all you have to do is let
us know and we go from there
today in active stream 16.2 the goal is
to learn discuss and hear from everybody
and just knowing dave and adam i think
will be able to have a really awesome
discussion where we are going to bring
up a lot of fun ideas centering and
strangely attracting back to this paper
the neural correlates to consciousness
under the free energy principle from
computational correlates to
computational explanation from visa and
firstin in 2020.
so today uh with a small group and a
follow-up discussion
there's a bunch of slides from last time
that we can definitely go to there's
also the paper itself but let's just
start with um an introduction so
we're gonna go around and introduce
ourself and again seeing as um just dave
adam and i are here we can each
introduce ourselves and maybe provide a
little context on some of these warm-up
questions so whichever of you two would
like to
go first um
we can still utilize hand raising or
perhaps it'll be a little easier um
to just have it like a regular
tripartite conversation so we'll go with
dave and then adam on the introduction
and on the context thanks
okay i'm gathering up
some reference material from a number of
different
ontologies
in order to get those aligned with the
topics for the edu project
i'm also going through a great big brain
dump from
the
most noted neuro psychoanalyst in south
africa who has give gotten two papers
and a book out just in the last two
weeks and i'm struggling through those
he has rewritten
the
project for a scientific psychology by
sigmund freud from 1895
in absolutely state-of-the-art
carl fristen
uh terminology the only thing he doesn't
hammer on a lot is specifically active
inference but all the other cool stuff
and it's just a brain breaker who is
this
thanks for the update um so we'll post
any links and we'll try to like keep it
on the discussion that people are here
to be listening about so if you have any
other thoughts dave otherwise adam go
for it
um
hi
uh
so i guess up uh
i'm adam uh
like an introduction or just what i'm
working on or just
how um say you know say hello we can
just ask how did we come to be here how
did we follow fall into a follow-up
discussion on a computational
consciousness paper
okay so um
i guess i have been
uh working for some time to try to
understand
uh
what the heck consciousness
is uh if that question even makes sense
uh
from different perspectives where the
free energy principle and active
inference um
has in general been i guess the
overarching view from which i'm
attempting to think
and so i've been
following what different people are
saying
proposing some ideas of my own um
and uh
just uh
along these lines of learning about
active inference i found like the live
streams and what daniel's doing and the
um
the discussions slash uh
potential movements that he's creating
and
um this is just one of the most uh
interesting conversations around as far
as i'm concerned
thanks adam
also dave i have a question i know you
have a lot of background in
classical cybernetics if it could be
called that so how does cybernetics deal
with this question of consciousness or
what have been some of the long-running
threads as far as the way cyberneticians
pre-active inference have been thinking
about this question
well
there's uh gregory bateson did a lot of
work on this in the 40s through the 60s
um
working as a therapist and as an uh arc
anthropologist
he
paid a lot of attention to
how people get fouled up
um he uses the term schizogenesis that
is the the origins of splits
sometimes it's a sort of a good thing
it's a way that a society can become
more differentiated
but in a child it's a great danger the
child for instance the uh
the thesis which turns out not to be all
that useful is that um
small children are constantly
misunderstanding what their parents are
saying the parents are not addressing
them very effectively they're assuming
the kids
either have less in intense in emotions
than they do
or that the kids understand more about
the shared the world of shared reality
so the kid will get flustered uh
demoralized alienated and in the best
case there's a reconciliation and the
the mother typically and the baby will
get back in sync they're now happy with
one another uh but sometimes the split
gets worse and worse and those same
combination of rage and demoralization
plays out into adulthood and
too often
as parents
uh and bateson uses draws a lot on great
on bertrand russell's theory of types
so he does he analyzes society's
interactions roles
with a very elaborate treatment of
hierarchies of meaning hierarchies of
reference hierarchies of control
and communication
uh so it loops right back to the old
definition of
the study of communication and control
and now my teacher gordon pasque put a
great deal of emphasis on two areas that
i i don't see addressed
adequately today
on the one hand
uh the inevitability of dialogue or
conversation in any
conscious occasion he says there's no
consciousness without dialogue
second point there's no consciousness in
fact no cons no concept without emotion
and third there's no persistent concept
without circular causation
and we know how important circular
causation is in explaining
how the mark of the the
markov bounded system and its
environment co-create
and stuart kaufman does a lot of
discussion of co-creation between the
niche
and the worker that is the organism the
society
the person the evolving language culture
whatever it might be
so it's not that these concepts are
completely missing but they're not as
articulated as they were even in the
1970s when pasc was developing the first
really effective
teaching learning
systems
with tiny clunky computers that were
half
made up of cards that people the the the
students had to be prompted to pick up a
cardboard card and put it on the display
because there was no way to display text
other than what you had to like little
lights and that would be labeled a1
which means go grab card a1 and read it
cool it's like we're better off now in
some ways sounds like playing battleship
with your computer um but
what you said there about the multiple
like perspectives in pursuing this
consciousness question there's the
anthropologist studying humans there's
the therapists who might be interested
in social systems more generally but
they're in a very specific relationship
and they might not be trying to do a
full ethnography or an anthropology
research project the therapist
relationship is one that's based upon
it's it's more medical it's based upon
helping reduce someone's suffering and
then even zooming out further and
further away from the experience there's
the biologist who might compare human
society or behavior with other animals
and then even a systems researcher that
might even go beyond the biological and
ask about where computers fit into all
this and so it's like in the center we
have our own experience and the
experience of other people and that is
what is negotiated
in that uh sort of kernel of the therapy
relationship or in the dialogue if it's
not which can be therapeutic even if
someone's uh not licensed but then we're
like going in these concentric shells
out
towards broader
systems thinking so i think that is what
i liked and remembered about the paper
and one of the things that motivates me
to
think about it go down different rabbit
holes and hear from people's
perspectives on it because there isn't a
priori a best approach and even within
an approach or one of those concentric
spheres it's not like there's one way to
do biology or one way to do anthropology
one way to do therapy so
how are we going to make adequate
guidance and navigation for the bigger
system
when
if we just get lost in all the possible
ways it could go then we are going to be
doing a lot of moving words around but
maybe not a lot of useful actions so
looking forward to hearing about that
and then also what you said about the
different developmental phases having
different cybernetic or communication
needs
so cybernetic principles like
having requisite variety or good
regulator whether we want to use the
classical cybernetic terminology or just
thinking about communicating systems
different developmental stages are able
to deal with different stresses and are
able to achieve different goals and so
there might be some things that are
overwhelming for a child but then maybe
later on we hope that that information
could be integrated or virtualized or
emulated or somehow
used in a controllable way
um any other just
off the top of the head thoughts because
i think we'll actually have a lot of
great
discussions stemming from just walking
through some of these slides is that
cool
all right nice
so just to recap maybe those who have
listened to the zero and one
conversations or not
but the paper that we're following up on
today is called the neural correlates of
consciousness under the free energy
principle from computational close to
computational explanation
and the
aims and the claims of the paper were to
integrate the neural correlates of
consciousness
with the computational correlates of
and
implicitly also the behavioral
correlates of consciousness bcc if we
could use that and then think about how
free energy principle and active
inference are going to be integrating
these
we went through the abstract
and uh the roadmap
last time
so today we're gonna just start off
by
uh looking at some of the questions that
people had raised in 16.1 which
we've now separated out into different
slides and added cc images in the
background so if anyone in the live chat
is just wanting to post a question or
something comes to mind we're definitely
open otherwise we'll just slowly march
through these fun slides and then
hopefully get to look at some of the
paper as well
so the first question and the one that
blue sort of brought back to the table
in 16.1 and
helped integrate into the construction
of 16.0 is how do we define and measure
consciousness so it's related to what is
consciousness
but we're almost approaching it
instrumentally instead of what is it
um which is the realism question we're
going to take the instrumentalist
approach how do we operationally define
it and how do we measure it or what are
we measuring because if you're
discussing what something is or isn't
without the instruments in mind how
you're actually going to be measuring it
or observing it
what is it going to be there for
so we had a few different terms that
people brought up
but
either of you would be welcome to give a
thought or adam might be curious just
from yeah you can speaking i'll ask you
a question too is in your
approach to studying consciousness what
measurements do you think are the most
important whether they're data sets we
already have or whether it's a kind of
data that doesn't quite exist yet but
what measurement would be the most
informative for you
oh
so
this is oh can you hear me yep
okay
um
microsoft says my microphone is noisy
but sometimes just the little background
sounds but it doesn't sound noisy to me
so i would let people know if it did
thanks
so i guess the approach i'm trying to do
is um
factorize as much as i can consciousness
into different senses of the word
and then try to bring those in
relation to each other in some coherent
way
and so
um i might think of consciousness in
terms of a set of uh concentric circles
which might be approached differently at
each level
so at maybe like the innermost
core shell we might have a minimalist
core you might have some kind of um
proto-creature consciousness we might
not even want to use the word some sort
of
organismic modeling
um
whether or not we talk about this terms
of consciousness could be a matter of
debate
and then
at some point we get to this like the
appearance of a world to a creature um
subjectivity uh what it is likeness
um
qualia
phenomenality
there's um
i i haven't heard like a definition that
really satisfies people universally and
they all sound very vague but just you
know the lights coming on what it is
like
uh to be us
um but then again since what is likeness
and then there's all the particular ways
of what it is like and now
the actual stream of experience is
shaped by
in different ways and has certain other
properties you might get into like
access consciousness so this would be
like networks distinctions between like
phenomenal consciousness or your
experience itself and this would be
where the framework like integrated
information theory would come in
um or you might have uh then another
level of complexity access consciousness
or the ability to manipulate um on the
objects of experience in your mind or
and report on them
um to have knowledge of them
but then it's like we're still somewhat
vague in terms of
what we mean by um uh knowledge of like
what how much knowledge what kind of and
so you might have even more
complexifications things like
self-consciousness like autonomic or
reflexive consciousness
and um it's
there there might not be like any bound
in terms of the complexification and so
at each level you might have a different
handling
and as you go like out at the outer
shells it seems like they blend
themselves best to operate
authorizationalization and
experimentation
where it's you know you can actually do
tests
did you um pass the mirror test even
though people
uh debate about what that means like do
you have certain can you report what's
the nature of the reports um how
sophisticated are they as you're dealing
with the more complex varieties of
conscious experience
so that's very straightforwardly lend
itself to empiricism as you start to go
into uh like i guess the phenomenality
itself to the to the degree that we want
to hold to this distinction between
phenomenal access consciousness or
different kinds i personally make use of
it but
once you get to experience itself you
have the problem of the first person
versus third person ontology the
privateness of it it's like you can make
inferences
about
different systems based on
their properties and what you think is
helpful for realizing
uh what might allow a world to appear to
a certain type of system but you can't
know because consciousness is private
you can only comment it indirectly and
so
it's
there's things like no report paradigms
people work with things like you know
are there coherent like um
most recently a paper just came out
looking for basically um uh
neurodynamics and are they responsive in
a certain way that um suggests like a
sensitivity to knowledge but still it's
an indirect influence and it's a problem
it seems like we always have to go
through usually
by some degree of directness report
and
to get it experienced
so it's to actually like where the
rubber hits the road of the initial
emergence of a world appearing to a
system
it's as far as i'm concerned really
super fraught and so my best attempt has
been to try to basically cross reference
as many perspectives as possible and try
to basically like line up
all three of like marion levels
to the extent i can of functional
algorithmic and implementation level
cross references with phenomenality and
then try to say okay
what types of
computational principles what types of
algorithms might help to create a world
that could appear
to a system
and
um
further thoughts on that but
i can
stop for now and keep talking about it
thanks
for this um this idea of
cross-referencing doing the scholarship
and really being up to date with what
people are actually asking and the ways
that they're really investigating it and
then looking for some underlying or some
inner
generative processes it's very
similar to what is being done in um
wonders
previous work on the minimum minimum
unifying models which is like could we
find a cluster of attributes that seem
to be
um co-extant like they're existing
together and then could there be some
minimal underlying
um speculated model that would lead to
those clusters of traits and then would
that help us design better experiments
reduce our uncertainty about how to act
and then the other part that i would
just ask about is like you know we hear
a lot about first person that's the i
and then we hear a lot about third
person like third person um bird's eye
view but then i'm wondering about this
second person because that's actually
where dave's questions um
about the no consciousness without
dialogue or without
interchange of information
as well as um
vygotsky and even demetrius boluses and
showbox work on becoming
who
we are through interaction so it's just
like
will we be able to localize it in the
brain or in the brain body or in the
brain body niche in the social niche
because if it turns out that it's
something that's distributed a little
bit beyond the cranium
then maybe neural measurements matter
maybe button tapping can matter
just like you could have one thermometer
and make an assessment about a broader
area but we shouldn't confuse the map in
the territory or the measurement and the
territory if we think it's relational
then any kind of objective measurement
is only ever going to tell a partial
picture
what do you think about that dave or how
does the second person come into play
i don't think i can advance the
discussion right now
yeah all good positions
yeah go ahead adam
um so
i think
in terms of like the release so i've
tended to um in terms of like degrees of
i guess internalism versus externalism
um i tended to i guess separate out
consciousness or
experience
from
a mind or intelligence
or modeling
where i think like the relevant um
generative modeling for
intelligence or mind would indeed be
distributed and extended and would spill
out beyond and exist between agents
um i've tended to reserve um
thinking of like a subset of these
generative processes a subset of
generative modeling
um
as being kind of stuck in the cranium of
the generation of consciousness itself
um
the and
even more i've tended to actually like
restrict it to even like not the full
like i wouldn't like draw the boundary
or the markov blanket across the whole
nervous system but actually
within the scope of these sort of
metastable
um
synchronous complexes which
through their synchrony would entail i
guess message passing in the calculation
of a
a joint estimate
over the entire
sensorium of the agent of its
embodied embedded interaction with the
world
and so for me this would be like not
even like the whole when these estimates
are being generated when these
metastable states are forming you could
think of them as a kind of um
non-equilibrium steady state um
that
there would be a
a general boundary around them that
wouldn't include the whole nervous
system and on the act
and but
um in terms of like practically
what would
so so in terms of like so in terms of
like the onion of consciousness in terms
of like the kind of consciousnesses that
we have that the exact nature of our
streams of experience our our
self-consciousness
and you know our
biographical you know auto and allo
biographical consciousness
um
that would definitely be relational that
would definitely be um
uh
even if like the like the pulp the
generative pulses for
the qualia might not be and any given
well they might be confined in the skull
the processes that where whereby
you would come to
model yourself in the world and we'd be
able to coordinate and just live that
would definitely be relational
um but
um i'm wondering whether the initial
generation of phenomenal itself while
practically
requiring for at least for mammals and
birds most of them
this communication this relationality
sometimes even maybe like a
bootstrapping or a back and forth
between perspectives between a second
person point of view and a first person
to actually
like you figure figuring out like who am
i by figuring out
that through interaction like who are
you who am i who am i in relation to you
and this is how you bootstrap the whole
thing and also just practically like um
i think you're later gonna have like
anna on and like this perspective of
like inherent interdependence you're not
gonna even be
homeostatic at all without the
relationality and so like the first
priors the exact nature of your
consciousness deeply interdependent that
being said
i wonder whether you can have systems
that are never in relation to any other
system
except for the world itself
and that
and that that they come to model
and that if they have the right
architecture that the
this could entail
an integrated world model
which would there be something that's
like to be such a system i don't know
where this begins and ends
but i have speculations but those are
some thoughts
it's definitely
clarifying where you're coming from with
the integrated world modeling it's
almost like if you could have a program
on a computer
that you you could know what was getting
passed into the program so you could say
yes when i hit run this program is going
to start from nothing or from the kernel
that i've specified and then if it ends
up doing this autopoesis or
self-reflection and then can do things
like the mirror test or
responding in a way that is akin to a
person
then
at least from a computational
perspective it's exhibiting some of
these important
features or attributes now you're still
going to have people who deny
consciousness or think everything has it
so for me
the question will
eternally be open because there's going
to be people who say it's all just an
illusion or it's not real
even for humans and there's other people
say well you just don't understand the
electron consciousness so you know
there's no point in even you know trying
to falsify that so it's going to remain
an open distribution
but we may be able to
focus
on some of these interesting
differences between ourselves and the
computational system it's like a little
model system
it's not the same thing as us but um
let's return to this computational
question because i think
it's related to the next question
with a jpeg of a hand reaching out to
the sky
how do we relate
experience or phenomenology
to
neural computational and all ad
behavioral dimensions
so
how do we connect
seemingly
it's it's like a a marketplace of two
different types you got the soda machine
that transforms the dollars into the
soda cans but how are we going to go
back and forth from a behavioral
observation to
phenomenology to computational i think
this is just it's definitely an open
question
like these are
just
starting point
discussions because
they're not resolved questions i would
say people barely even know what the
structure of a resolution would look
like
but it has related to
this
question we just asked which is for a
virtual machine or for any type of
system
for it to interface out
to the outside world so in active
inference we call that action states
whether it's typing or your voice box or
whether it's your eye movements it's an
active state um it's part of the blanket
states with sense and action so however
you come to know about a system through
the act action and sensory states
you're not going to have access to those
internal states and then it's almost
like even if you knew it those internal
states where it wouldn't always clarify
the situation so
how do we um think about this connection
or the interface between systems of
different kinds virtual machines
or
seemingly conscious systems how are
those linked to the outside world and
how do we
talk about that rigorously and then i
believe it was um cambridge breaths last
time who just
at the end brought up this question
about quantum and classical computation
it's not
something i know a ton about but it's
interesting to think about whether the
sort of
turing computation zero one von neumann
architecture just what people think of
when they hear a computer just like this
laptop in front of me
how is that
part of a broader perspective on
computation especially when we're
thinking about computational dimensions
like we're not just thinking about
windows 10 we're thinking maybe about
unconventional computation and
um
so these were just some questions that
people addressed if anyone
has a thought they can go for it
otherwise we can just keep on walking
through it yep go for it
so i guess um
i might start with um
neural behavioral in terms of like in
the systems where i think i have some
understanding and then move into more
general like
types of computational systems that
could potentially
realize things similarly whether we're
talking about
like a von neumann architecture
or like the blackhead experiment with
the nation of china
or
like use social insect colonies
you know any kind of system but like
starting from i guess where we have
maybe the most purchase
it would seem
to me
um
that experience
would correspond to potentially
or try to like identify a
neurocomputational object of a joint
marginal distribution
um
from a probabilistic world model
which would over you basically the
sensorium of the organism as as it is
coupling with the world
and so
for
me it would be basically an estimation
of
a visual spatial field
um which would connect to like uh
rudroff's work with the projected
conscious modeling a point of view
but also
um the feeling of having a body the
lived body
and the relation between these things um
potentially involving something like an
attention schema like bringing like
graziano's type of work and so i'm
basically thinking like all like
many different theories of consciousness
are actually pointing to different
aspects of what we need with none of
them being uh on their own jointly
sufficient but if we bring them together
we might be able to get joint
sufficiency and so
the idea in terms of neural substrates
i'm thinking that the appearance of a
visual world could correspond to
basically
um some kind of maybe the pecunius um
this like midline structure as like the
top of the since the top of the visual
spatial sensorium um coupling with the
posterior cingulate um
and the reason i would like point to
these i guess would be partially
empirically in terms of like what
happens if you lesion these areas
and also the types of information
available to them so it's both like
where they are their high centrality um
being hierarchically higher
the empirical associations like if you
lesion the posterior the pecunius you're
going to have um
lots of problems but also in terms of
mental imagery this is like these would
be
neural corals that tend to be associated
i i bring in like the cingulate because
you're seeing that because um basically
i think that area might be the most
crucial one for establishing a
particular point of view on the world
so you would have there's this like old
idea of the pez circuit where um he was
basically um dropping electrodes kind of
like figure out epileptic form loci and
you feel like this highly central
inner circuit for emotional memory where
you go from the mammillary bodies
to i think it's like the
anterior lateral thalamus
posterior cingulate into the hippocampal
formation
out through the phorinx back to the
mammary bodies and like this this basic
loop
of emotional memory i bring it up
because if you think of the types of
information that you would get there
part of what the mammillary bodies are
doing is they have this um stretch
receptor information from the neck and
so this will actually tell you like
where your inner lamprey's head is
pointing
and then if you go to the um the
thalamic nuclei they're now getting that
information they're also getting
information from the vestibular
apparatus
and so you have from the inner ear this
like crazy conch shell nautilus i don't
know how to describe this like crazy
shape that basically has these like
little particles that move around and
stimulate these hair cells that cause
different action potentials so basically
you can get the yaw pitch and roll of
the head
and so you're getting both like the
positional and the vector information of
your head
coming into
this area before it feeds into the
hippocampus's top of the cortical cutter
or gate that basically gets your entire
sensorium all the modalities coming
together pegged according to what you
need for an egocentric uh perspective
and reference frame anyway so that would
be like any human
yeah just one one note on this because i
think it's really important is um the
question of estimating a visual field
isn't like just what a convolutional
neural network does it's not just a fill
in the dots paint by lines
as we heard from rudraf and willaford
and and others it's actually a very
of a complex affordance driven
projective model
that entails a locus of the observer so
if a computer is trying to auto complete
some image
it is taking a matrix and it's doing
transformations based upon statistical
regularities in a matrix so we can sort
of computationally sketch that out but
in the um locus of our awareness
visually even it's not quite even the
same computational problem because it's
integrated like you're saying with um
inputs of information that we can
observe and you you made a great point
with the the neck position and then the
angle of your ear
it's probably super non-linear how that
gets integrated into the control
mechanisms but that's like the um
gyroscope and acceleration on a phone
it actually does convey the information
about
the pitch and direction but then it's
being conveyed in this very
action-oriented way and that's
egocentric action oriented because
otherwise
if you're if you're calculating the
actions for somebody else
what's the point
and in some ways it might even be the
lion's share of the information and like
except for rare circumstances like
unless you're in like the midst of a
gale force hurricane it might be like
the most
purchase you have on like what the like
what is causing the most change in your
sensorium would be your own
self-generated actions whether we're
talking about like overt motions or like
now i'm changing what's coming in or
like even just the might like or cicadas
at three times a second or even like
these potentially faster jiggles and
microcycles like it's actually all
coming from you and if you're gonna try
to make sense of like make sense of your
sensors without this it might be pretty
hopeless unless you're actually
accounting for this inactive
embedded
like
situating of of of what's coming in
and so yeah you need all this
information
for uh
you know we're not just like sitting
there locked in
videos being displayed in us with our
eyes open like in clockwork orange you
know it's we're actually engaged in the
world and even there your eyes are
moving around even there would be
hopeless without the efference copy
here's a fun thing is in active
inference we know that the imperative is
to reduce surprise minimize free energy
of a system and there's two ways the
system can go about doing that it can
learn which is updating its internal
model or it can act so you could do
action or inference
integrated under the same imperative and
so let's think about this super
clockwork orange 1984 situation where
even the oculomotor
muscles have been paralyzed so someone
cannot blink they can't move their eyes
and they're get they're they're it's
like just they can't act at all they're
maybe in a hopeless yes
in that situation
there would be an internal experience
let's just say
and um because they couldn't
act
all the adaptation and the free energy
minimization would have to be
based upon their internal model now
their internal model could be a
crystallization of i don't like what's
happening to me and i'm not
listening to the propaganda and that's
not me for example
but that's not um always
maybe the case and then we can go from
that super limited uh situation
into cases where we actually do have
degrees of freedom of action
and degrees of freedom of thought and
it's a really interesting point that
our active experimentation in the
environment
is what is leading along the trajectory
of our experience it's like oh what's on
the other side of this pen i picked it
up and now all the experiences my arm
all my visual field is different but
that wasn't externally induced
it was part of an endogenous
active sequence of active
experimentation in the niche
and then
so it's really okay cool that's where we
get action and inference coming together
so continue on
like an ai like they're trying to like
figure out how to get inductive biases
for things like objectness and different
kinds of core knowledge
and i think it's actually um a real
problem that they're
that this inactivist perspective is
lacking
because they just want to sort of like
plop in um different as coronology's
different evolutionary priors as
inductive biases right from the
beginning so it's like you have somehow
you know wave your hands bay's magic
object is prior causation you might have
things such as this but it's going to
actually be helpful
for an object inspire if the system
actually has
experience with objects that might be
helpful and and it's still this idea
that like you're trying to solve vision
completely divorced
from the engagement with the world so
you can actually like reach up and
if you have experiences like do
touching and moving things around it's
like huh i have uncertainty i'm gonna
like you're just saying i can resolve my
energy
oh that's what's on the other side and
now i'm building up an object model and
now i'm building up causal models of
like what happens if like i let go of
this i'm not going to do it but
now you've had
a sense of the causation of the world
that is basically allowing you to have
this internal model instead of just like
hammering it into the architecture
somehow through something like you know
some sort of architectural prior i'm not
that those things don't exist and are
going to be crucially important
but i think it's completely hopeless
that they're going to solve that
enduring problem of ai
without
this inactivist perspective i think it's
just the hypothesis space is way too
unconstrained you will be lost there
forever you can throw all the compute of
the universe at it it still might not be
enough i could be wrong about that but
that's
yep oh that's a clean
another way of thinking about that is
like let's say the space of all possible
chess boards or the space of all
possible cup designs it's a big number
but actually the space of all strategies
for chess
it has to be bigger than the number of
chess boards because any chess board
there's multiple strategies or the strat
the number of strategies for determining
the coffee cup like what is each joint
gonna do
as you're seeking to infer what kind of
coffee cup it is again it's like chess
strategies it's another level
of strategy above the state
and so active inference sort of cuts the
knot
on seemingly the simpler problem how do
we figure out what kind of coffee cup it
is rather than just doing exhaustive
mapping of all possible coffee cups we
actually step back to asking what
strategy is going to help us resolve
uncertainty about the coffee cup
and then that strategy
might be encapsulated with just a few
lines of pseudo code like a good
strategy for game theory might be start
nice and retaliate but then act randomly
once in a while and forget sometimes
something like that that's quite a
compression
of a lot of things that are relational
in the world and so it's almost like
sometimes the state estimate is
too hard or not even what we really want
to know you don't want every pixel in hd
of your visual field you need to know
how to act and then that way even if
you're um
if you have something in your eye or one
eye is injured or there's some sort of
other visual impairment or even no
visual input
someone can still act
effectively whereas if you just have an
image recognition module you disconnect
that and now it's like you're you're you
know walking on
nothing but if you have action as the
core loop
and then sense as it is an active
inference is being integrated to the
extent um that it shapes action it's a
very different perspective than sort of
this input process output
control theory model and i think this is
going to come back in a second when we
look at the circular closed causality of
the actual action inference loop with a
blanket state intermediating so that's
pretty cool any other thoughts there
um i guess along those lines um
something that's something an open
question for me right now
and also speaks to like illusionism you
mentioned recently um i i
i kind of bristle against all things
illusionist um in that like uh i think
indeed
i think it implies things like it
implies things like you are not
conscious or that consciousness is not
um an important um
basically adaptation or component of
experience but this the idea that it
might be different than we think i think
is valid and useful so in that sense
i like illusionism but i also bristle
against it but the idea with though
being with this sort of
the the most useful compression and the
most useful like how is the how is it
encoded um
what is the richness of experience we
could actually be somewhat mistaken
and that it might be as if we have this
hd visual field all available to us all
at once or it might just be when we
query it
we can have it when we need it
and so um like i think uh is it a reagan
i think like with sensory motor
contingency theory that's his model and
it's more extended and it's like you
just query the environment
but um potentially like even internally
you might just be querying an entailed
like generative world model and it might
even be potentially
at the
resolution of the sensory engagements
themselves which are like for instance
for visual sampling you have basically
for the phobia it's it's a thumbnail
held out at arm's length that's
basically all you got
and so it might be in any given moment
that is actually what's in your ex your
visual experience it could be but it's
just you're moving it around and so you
never notice because there's no place to
stand to look at yourself not realizing
it's like kind of like the
refrigerator-like like whenever you open
it there it is
um
interesting so it delights this one
i map like though like part of like
perceptually like i suggest that there
is some sort of richer filling and this
is part of like i think so like um i've
suggested and can i have suggested that
like you can think of cortex in terms of
principles of like variational auto
encoders and part of what they can do is
they can fill in a more rich thing so
for instance they might be used for
instance like for like a a 4k or an 8k
television or something for like super
resolution for up sampling and you have
a
more impoverished signal and then you
film the missing details or you have
like an included image and then you fill
in wasn't there and this maybe this is
like for instance
partially how we handle the blind spot
that's unclear
but how much filling in exactly happens
i have no idea it could be just like
almost like an etch-a-sketch thing that
is at the really shockingly
low dimensional
uh
resolution of the actual sensors
themselves or not i don't know
another thought on the richness or the
paucity those are comparators they're
relative terms and so imagine another
agent in the niche has different
affordances and say only 400 to 700
nanometers you know you can't see
anything beyond this it's like who's
having a rich experience now and so we
are having our experience and then as
you're pointing out
feeling like things are uh not changing
or like we have good clarity outside of
our main focal point that's a story
we're telling ourselves that actually
might be a very adaptive and
self-protective belief because if it's
the case that when we're unsure about
something it produces or it is anxiety
and then tunnel vision is like sort of
our de facto sensory reality as far as
what the resolution capacity of the
retina is so
how do you square the circle with
limited sensory capacity but not wanting
to have over anxiety well you make rapid
cicading and then you have a continual
story that everything is okay until
something semantically is not okay in
the visual field um dave
yeah uh did you see the uh
the youtube address that i just sent
through chat several minutes ago
um i don't look at any chats during the
live stream but what can you tell us
about it or how would people find it
yeah
yeah this is a recent um
presentation by mark sorms about
uh why
summarizing his rece his book that just
came out um and he's
he's he's addressing how it is that
thomas nagle and david chalmers ask
these really good questions really
important questions super smart people
the tremendous amount of knowledge have
been working at this for decades
and they've some of them are despairing
how can we ever possibly answer these
questions
and he said well if you refuse to pay
attention to the brain
stem and the midbrain and think you're
going to find the answers to
consciousness and what it's to be like
and
feeling
in the cortex
you are not going to find it because it
ain't there there is you want to know
what does it feel like and you want to
look at and you're you've confined
yourself to a part of the brain where
feeling isn't happening the part that
isn't dedicated to feeling but rather is
a sort of
you might say computing machine that
might pick up some consciousness when
the brain stem needs the neocortex to do
consciousness rather to help it do
consciousness
so i'll send um
i don't know maybe i should send an
email or the other thing leave a comment
on this youtube video and if someone's
curious they'll check back out i don't
know if i can do that i don't know that
i i've tried to put comments on the
youtube and i see no evidence that
anything that i put in ever goes
anywhere that anybody can see
interesting
but anyhow yeah but suddenly you can put
it in the in the the text maybe later on
the other thing uh maybe you both heard
me talk about this before but uh some
folks working on uh
the memory
that's used for chess the recognition of
chess positions
uh they took a bunch of people from just
really beginners who just basically know
only how you can move what are the legal
moves to really good players to masters
and they would give them chest positions
and let them look at it for a few
seconds or 30 seconds or however long
that was that was varied and then say
now write it down for me or just say
tell me what you can remember about it
you know 30 60 seconds or 15 minutes
later
and
in a real position
the master was really really good they
could sometimes reproduce all of the
pieces in an endgame or a mid game
and the amateurs couldn't could barely
do it at all they say well uh white's
kind of still in white's territory and
the right side of the board had a lot of
stuff in it but if they put up
impossible positions positions that you
cannot possibly legally move position
pieces into
the masters would get really upset
because they couldn't remember i don't
know i don't know
in fact the amateurs were better than
the masters
at reproducing
impossible boards
and the folks analyzing this said this
well it seems like people don't remem
people who know chess don't remember
positions at all
they remember
trajectories
that seems to be the only thing they
remember and then they they drill down
on that you know how can you distract
from remembering trajectories and and so
on and they says yeah this seems to be
what people remember the meaningful
moves they don't remember
positions i think that might address
some of the things adam was saying about
what's what's really deflated what is
really the more efficient way to to
uh store data uh you've got storage in a
computing machine
and you've got
the knowledge and the information and
the
information about my
position and where i want to go from
here
the living brain uses and they may have
no relation
thanks for that dave and i'm going to
pass to you adam with a question from
the chat um cambridge breaths asks a
question to adam regarding the
computational approach to
neurophenomenology how would the
generative passages possibly help to
describe consciousness in a way that
generative models can't do
so it sounds kind of related i'm not
sure about the degenerative passage but
it's sort of this trajectory idea i
think is what we're getting at so
anything you wanted to say or respond in
that
okay so um
there's a few things off the stack and
i'll address that if i can
um or to the extent i can
oh with relation to the um different
types of um uh
potential illusion or
richness or lack thereof um just there's
this one book that reviews a lot of
these phenomena the mind is flat by nick
shader
which is interesting um
i know if the book should be called the
mind is flat or the mind is surprisingly
rich and deep it just it's a better
perspective but um
with respect to and i also want to
address uh psalms and the idea of a
conscious brain stem which i'm going to
push back on that a little bit
um
the
but i guess i'll go to the generative
passages versus um like generative model
idea
um and i i think that that first and i
think that actually speaks to
what you were saying daniel in terms of
like
wanting to have this balanced
information like dealing with what's the
information you actually got
um and then what can the agent handle in
terms of it's like um
it's
effective read on itself by which it's
regulating itself as a cybernetic system
not getting overwhelmed by uncertainty
any given point and potentially a kind
of
additional filling in both for the sake
having
um
like a richer cause of the world but
also just to not freak out the agent
to allow it to be more copacetic
in handling the uncertainty that it's
going to have to handle
in engaging with the world and trying to
via potentially some sort of integrated
world model
now the
i guess the
i'm still um
trying to understand aspects of the like
so the distinction between uh so there's
a pre-print that just came out um by
maxwell ramsey and a few others on
neurophenomenology which is which talks
about
this generative passage idea
um but
i guess part of it would be if
the modeling processes we're doing are
temporarily deep
and they're counterfactually rich
and this would be different than for
instance just necessarily
inverting
your degenerate model from your
sensoring so like for instance if you
take
the posterior lobes it might
um
which iit says are the physical
substrates of consciousness and
could be
on another perspective viewed as like a
kind of workspace that provides a global
availability or could be viewed as like
a predictive global journal workspace
this could be
um
uh predicting what you think your
century states are each at each point
um
this
this could get you a good amount of
temporal depth and counter factual
richness however
really though the unfolding is um
not just a sequence of sensory estimates
just stitched together your time but
it's they're inactively stitched
together through time where they're actu
the whole process whether you're
engaging the world or you're imagining
it it's these action perception cycles
and so now the frontal lobes are in the
mix and now it's getting complicated but
now the agent is shifting its
perspective around
um within either
an actual world's engagement or some
sort of virtual world
and
with some sort of relation between these
this is now more extended this is a
different thing where um the closure of
these functional cycles the
informational closure um is
more extended so things like for
instance the temporal the the inherent
depth of the present moment the sort of
specious present
that might be part of it in terms of for
instance it's not just this
as i'm suggesting like the actual quail
are discrete they're being estimated at
alpha frequencies
primarily with a foci kind of
encompassing the posterior lobes and
this is where you're getting
basically these nests these
non-equilibrium steady state densities
or i call them self-organizing harmonic
modes and this is the stream of
experience however
the actual what's in the stream
that's
involving other things that's involving
this the cybernetic action perception
context and where it begins and ends um
the actual operations engagement that's
a different and much more complicated
story and i think we're basically going
to need to have things
actually think like the hippocampal
system might be at the core of that and
that's going to be like the key puzzle
piece i'm currently working on moving
from basically this basic like what
could do phenomenality to what could do
these more complex forms i'm trying to
grop the hippocampal system to figure
that out but that's like one distinction
between like generative
i think i might speak to generative
passages versus just the components of a
gender model to be being inverted that
could entail
um basic
creature consciousness phenomenally or
just the the
estimates of the world the stream of
experience i don't know if that makes
sense okay so one more thing though yeah
or just one on the passage just we'll
then we'll go to the other topic so
think about um memorizing something like
the chess board but think about
memorizing a sequence of sounds so if
there's sounds that you cannot make like
um some sort of whistle or some sort of
sound that a human can't make it's going
to be really hard to memorize it you
could recognize it but it's going to be
hard to reproduce it now there's sounds
that you can make in a language you
don't know if you tried hard enough you
might be able to memorize a song in a
different language but it's going to be
hard
next would be in the scale of how easy
it is to memorize would be like random
words in english or language that one
speaks but not grammatical that's like
the chess boards that are impossible
it's real pieces but it's not linked in
a way okay now up another level of easy
to memorize natural language like
conversation could be pretty easy to
memorize
another layer up would be a composed
natural language like a story or a poem
and then even above the story or the
poem
as we know from those who have great
experience with memorizing
epics
is the embodied and the inactive poem so
where um from the head of the story to
the to the toes of the story or it it
invokes your own body and so when we
think about this generative passage it's
almost like it's increasingly natural
for us to um
condense or to distill
memory in terms of a narrative
at increasingly inactive increasingly
self-referential ways
instead whereas stimuli that aren't able
to be easily brought on board our own
narrative
in a relational way
they're kind of like non-sequiturs to
our
memory
and so that's who and what we are uh the
stay of the system and how response and
then also on the passage versus the
generative model thinking about the
generative model even though we know in
active inference that it's beyond
internalism and externalism and tale of
two densities and so it's not just like
the generative model is a matrix but
thinking about a generative model makes
you think that you can like pause the
sensory input and just okay what's the
state of the model but when we think
about generative passages and trajectory
estimates we get past present future we
get self and other and we get planning
under uncertainty so those are some of
the very very key aspects of passage
inference that aren't quite captured by
just asking about generative model which
makes it sound like you're doing like a
linear regression
okay then to the other aspect
yep
that was beautifully said uh
um just need a moment
okay
um
yeah so um
okay so for i guess the the brainstem
part um
so
i i really like um marx home's
perspective and i'm actually uh
very sympathetic to neuropsychoanalysis
um i think it's developmental it's
relational i think it um acknowledge
like i think basically since we we are
either you know we say
because we're reinforcement learners it
would be shocking if there weren't
things like defense mechanisms because
there's uh some thoughts you're having
more of some things
you're having less of and the
contingencies of value and optimization
are too numerous and varied sometimes
subtle for you to track
and so you can go down all sorts of
garden paths so i'm generally like while
the particular aspects of the freudian
framework you might question i think we
probably should be thinking something
kind of psychoanalytic to get at the
weirdness of mind and what it's like to
be a person that being said
um
while i agree about the fundamental
nature of the necessity
of the brain stem
as part of what's contributing to
consciousness
um as
not just
as being necessary you take it out
you're done however
the claim that brings himself is the
locus of consciousness i find to be
somewhat questionable
um and that i think we're in an even
worse position
in some ways um
well
we're it it's
the reason i would say so one i i would
question the evidence that's cited for
this
um but the other is i think you probably
need the
at the very least something like to do
temporarily deep
generative modeling
of a kind that would be able to give
rise to an integrated world model
it seems like the branson doesn't have
what it takes i suspect you need the
flamma coracle system with its ability
to do
this hierarchical sequence memory and
its ability to
capture this hierarchy of time scales
all coupled
to
model
your
hierarchically
your hierarchy or the dynamics unfolding
heart rate and your engagement with the
world you need a system that has those
properties and i don't think the branson
quite has what it takes
um
the you know basically for me to have
consciousness i want to have
i as i say an integrated world modeling
theory i want
the um an integrated role model that has
coherence with respect to space time and
cause and maybe also um agency some sort
of basic autonomy as part of it and
these are all necessary properties that
potentially might be jointly sufficient
but they're definitely necessary and so
i don't think the branson can do all
that
um in terms of the data they cite um
one would be um an
ant phallic patients or um
children without a developed verbal
cortex
and um or whether it's just not there
and they're showing like this rich
emotionality
but
my pushback would be um that
that's
that emotions they go all the way back
um
all life like that's like and like
demacia's thinking and like the strange
order of things
um and the um
2012 book i forgot what that one's
called but it's
this
every single this it's these coherent
changes and organismic modes
that are corresponding to
means of engaging with the world these
classes of events and this is a state of
basically action readiness over your
system that allows you to adaptively
couple and i think like this is what
emotions are and so this is being shaped
all the way back to a single cell and
maybe we want to push consciousness that
far down i personally wouldn't but the
idea is i think you can have very rich
unconscious emotions very rich affects
and it should be organized
organismically and so this will all be
the level of the brainstem you'll see
these things you'll see like for
instance potentially laughter you'll see
fear you'll see rage
but i would argue you'll see in some
ways homologs of these things going all
the way back to bacteria bacteria going
into like a sporulated form to protect
itself
that could be a kind of like fear thing
or a bacteria releasing endotoxins that
could be a kind of anger response or
like extending a pilus to exchange
circular chromosome little chromosome
bits of 100 that could be a kind of
bacterial lust
i don't think there's anything it's like
for these affects for the bacteria so i
kind of push back and that basically the
reflex these reflex arcs being engaged
coherently
for
these things that are basically at the
core of our experience was
some of the most important part
still
um i think this can be done uh
potentially just mechanically and like
from like a kind of brooksian robotics
emergency perspective uh where it's
just the
systems intelligence is in
it's
the what's available like the different
modes its body can go into which will um
allow for certain types of adaptive
coupling yep it's the one more thing i
would say would be um they also point to
um
the so like um like you got pancetta
like you'll stimulate these areas and
then they'll generate the emotion
okay um
but i think that might be the same story
like the generation of affects we don't
know right or rather okay so we know if
you stimulate it
in us
so you can stimulate these areas and
you'll generate the ocean but that that
area itself is sufficient for it that we
don't know i would suggest probably not
and then for us if we experience the
issue though is you have these looping
effects you haven't cut it off it's
circular causation so you stimulate
these like brain stem nuclei or
hypothalamic nuclei and then you
generate the emotion well the cortex is
still online for us
and so that's
uh i i would quite i basically i think
the evidence is questionable for the the
conscious brainstem
even though i love everything else about
someone's perspective
i think we should move away from
conscious brainstorms
okay thank you yeah this um
freud talks about
different qualitatively different kinds
of consciousness the consciousness
that's in the brainstem and the cortical
at least though i'm sorry i shouldn't
say it that way the way psalms updates
freud that there's certain consciousness
that does seem to be confined to the
brain stem and i know listening to his
talks
he he will say it's conscious and then
in the next sentence it's unconscious
and
that
that differentiation is really important
it may be that if we were in the habit
of talking about what i'm canning just
now versus what we're witting
it wouldn't be as confusing if we
separate the body knowledge from the
um
visual knowledge or visual
oral knowledge thank you yep thanks for
that dave and um
i'm not ready to say that consciousness
isn't a helpful word but when you're
talking about subtypes just brainstem
function or the neural computational
components of brainstem function in this
or that state it's all of a sudden like
it's like explained away
and then also this question about the
lesions and the measurements which is
what is really important to us when
we're thinking about this pragmatically
it reminds me a lot of genetics where
they'll take a gene even just going with
the molecular dna concept of a gene so
just saying they'll take a gene and
they'll knock it out or they'll remove
its function and then let's say blood
pressure goes up when you delete the
gene and they'll say oh well then this
gene lowers blood pressure because it
went up without it but that's actually
not true to use out of your terminology
the blood pressure is a phenotype that
is like a self-organized harmonic mode
and then when you change one of the
nodes
it's going to lead potentially to a
if it's a buffered node then it's not
going to change the mode at all so it'd
be like a phenotypically silent mutation
or it could be like a key linchpin just
like the you know epigenetic landscape
behind me um it changed one of these
guys that are key
and then it changes the self-organizing
mode and so just like you said a brain
region when you lesion it if it removes
some trait that doesn't mean the trait
was in that region it's actually a total
integrated network and then you change
the network or the system's phenotype
when you change the system so i'm always
extremely skeptical of well this removal
of this brain region remove this trait
so it's in there it's like actually you
could almost say it isn't in there
because the system was able to
reorganize without it and so it's just
it's it's almost like the opposite of
what people think is being shown with
lesion experiments it's being shown that
the system has capacity
that is modified by key elements like if
you inject ketamine you know into your
wrist there's going to be a different
phenotype than if it goes into some
brain region like there's brain regions
where a different drug being dripped on
is going to lead to different phenotypic
changes so that's actually not simply
evidence that the brain is the locus of
consciousness it's just saying yeah
there's you know your elbow is a pivotal
spot for the movement of your arm and
there's brain regions that
play critical message passing roles and
neural functional roles
but that doesn't uniquely identify this
sort of object reductionist um or
regional perspective
um this is fun stuff i think we can um
let's
um adam yeah go for it yeah yeah
um
i guess in terms of um things like
uh
virtual machines
and what what's
types of systems so i'm like kind of
pushing back on brainstorms but i'm also
um in some ways broader i guess than
like um maybe potentially wandering
carl's perspective and that i'm actually
really happy with consciousness
being supported by a virtual machine in
fact i think you might want to even
think about it as a kind of virtual
machine
um
and
for me
um though part of what i want to have
happen it's not just this potentially
the ability to have um
you know a hierarchy
of representation
with like synchronous dynamics
facilitating the message passing but
what i'm going to want is for basically
these estimates of the organisms
or the the system's engagement with the
world
to be generated
on a time scale
that would allow it to both inform and
be informed by evolving action
perception cycles
and where basically the role for me of
this basic phenomena awareness would be
a series of estimates who through their
basically
high degree of coherence can also exert
um
powerful control energy they end up
constituting this center um
slow
synergetic attracting manifold that can
enslave the rest of the system to
degrees and influence its its dynamics
basically influencing action selection
series of estimates that can influence
action selection and be updated
via your engagement
so this doesn't necessarily need to be a
brain but for me i want that i want
basically a rich enough estimate of the
global state
of the system and i want these estimates
to be
occur on a time scale where they can
significantly
enough that there's a good amount of
grip enough that you can actually do
active inference both in form and be
informed by
the engagement i want one more thing
potentially or maybe two more
um which would be um i would want uh
a
um
[Music]
a large enough network
that you can get some sort of
non-equilibrium steady state or
self-organizing harmonic mode among some
aspect of it some subset of it
um
which
would
where the closure would be achieved
within this system
that there that you could describe such
a object such a harmonic or such a nest
density
and
i think what you might potentially need
is a big enough system
that
you're can get almost like an inner loop
or that when you're forming this
metastable state it's not immediately
disrupted by the engagements with the
world
via the sensory states and so i want to
be big enough
that there's this
it can form these internal
complexes can i tie this to a question
in the chat because i think it's great
okay cambridge breaths asks
carl fristen was asked if hurricanes
have a markov blanket
he said reluctantly no
what would that say about markov
blankets in general and is there any
mathematical way to attribute markov
blanket to a hurricane so i'm going to
put up the image where we have the
blanket states whether it's a markov or
a first in blanket and the internal
states with a generative model but what
you just said there about the
persistence through time of an inner
loop
how would you relate that to this
question about the hurricane and about
what systems like is a hurricane
conscious
um it has little inner loops doesn't it
little turbulent eddies but what is it
about the sort of like sustained memory
and this inner looping
where does that come into play and
is that a way almost to go about
identifying which systems
hint might be able to be measured as
conscious because they'll have an
internal dynamics
that um are complex
no idea especially with the hurricane
but
although a thought that i've been like
trying to think into recently
is
um
i'm wondering whether this inner loop
might actually be important
so maybe we can only define a markov
blank a fristen blanket mark all blanket
when you have
this sort of
separability and maybe only for these
like inner loop processes if you're not
basically immediately being disrupted
by the engagement where you can't draw
the boundaries just like immediately
effaced
um and that would still you could still
do an inference maybe they'll be kind of
like i don't know if it'd be amortized
influence but it'll be you could still
do inference and coupling but it
wouldn't be this uh
uh
you you wouldn't have these series of
estimates but the
thing i'm wondering actually is whether
in some ways
the solution to the hard problem and the
solution to what is life
along the lines of markovian modernism
even though
uh it might be one and the same
and that like the boundary of life
non-life the boundary of conscious
non-conscious
what actually makes for this
adaptiveness is to have estimates which
can evolve slightly independently
from
the world such that you can do things
like counterfactuals
in terms of your modeling so you can get
this sort of um
sussing out of different possibilities
and then using this as a means of
surfing your uncertainty your engagement
now i wouldn't want to go as far as to
say that all life is conscious i'm not
personally of that view like you can
make a case for it because i want the
additional coherence properties i don't
think all life has but this idea though
that the boundary problem of life and
non-life of unconscious information
processing or unconscious perception
conscious perception it might be exactly
the same issue
let's connect it let's connect it to
what the paper says because i think this
is really
what we're on the brink of so this is
quotations from the paper this is about
where
free energy principle and active
inference is going to step into some of
these very challenging perennial
questions like what is consciousness how
do we measure it who gets to have it so
the first summary point of wanja and
carl was according to free energy
principle we need to be thinking about
neurodynamics not just neural states so
i think that's very related to what
we've been talking about not just the
states like oh well this neuron has this
action potential and this one's doing
that we need to think about the
trajectory through time so short clean
point and the third point is also a
short clean point it's more of like a
literature claim which is that other
people's models were generalizing above
them okay so the first and the third
point i think are um
short and sweet
let's really go into the second point
because it relates to
what's the difference between being
conscious and simulating consciousness
people can have different opinions on
this but this is where the authors are
taking it and then what kind of
biological or non-biological systems
might have or be conscious so hurricane
how about a pilot in the hurricane what
if the hurry yeah so what do they
actually say here according to the free
energy principle there's a relevant
distinction to be made between the
probabilities of the neural states
um or the trajectories and the
probabilities they encode so i i think i
had to read this a bunch of times
because they sound so familiar but it's
basically saying there's the probability
of the neural state itself
um which is like the probability of the
brain is in that exact stance which is
actually never going to return to
and the probabilities that the brain is
encoding
so um for example if the brain is
involved in a
decision making task
there's the probability of the
microstates the brain which you can go
reduce all the way down and it's never
going to replicate those microstates so
instead of focusing on the probability
of the states or even the probabilities
of the trajectories which are always
going to be vanishingly zero
we can think about what are the
probabilities encoded by those states
like the action readiness is this person
in a global dynamic state where they're
action ready to move like they're awake
or they're not action ready so they're
like asleep
how are we going to do this
subtle shift from thinking about the
probabilities of states and trajectories
versus the probabilities encoded by
states and trajectories well this is
where they introduce the information
geometry
and they call this partitioning between
the probability of the state and the
probability encoded by the state as
intrinsic versus extrinsic information
geometry
so in line with this distinction neural
dynamics
are movements on this intrinsic
statistical manifold
and then the computational component
what the observer
is modeling them as what's the shortest
algorithm that generates that behavior
that is movement on the extrinsic
manifold
and so this relates to what is being
conscious versus simulating it
for
the um hurricane
let's just say
those two manifolds are actually
mapped like there's no hidden states the
microstates and the macro states are um
[Music]
they're
they're they're one and the same
whereas when you have systems that are
engaged in these very
vanishingly rare micro states but then
they converge upon reproducible
algorithmic or computational or
behavioral features
that partitioning can tell us something
if there's a system where those are one
in the same like it's a double pendulum
and you're curious about its behavior it
still could be chaotic but there's no
like hidden interactors whereas there's
other systems where computationally we
have to approach them in a really
different way i'm not sure if that's
correct but that's kind of what we tried
to um
read about in this paper and explore
where is the intrinsic and extrinsic
concepts coming into play
and how do we
how do we take all these interesting
things that are happening here and
move towards a definition or some sort
of um
operationalization adam
yep go for it
i don't know
but
um
that won't stop me um
so
i guess
so as i was saying before i think
actually we might want to think of
consciousness
as a kind of virtual machine
and i think especially once we get to
this sort of generative passages and
these richer senses of consciousness i
think we're definitely dealing with a
virtual machine in these cases
um
but
in terms of this um this maybe this
place where it's this one-to-one
mapping between the extrinsic and
intrinsic
manifolds is this one-to-one mapping of
information geometries
um
i guess at least within
kind of come back to brains
i'm
so for instance i focus on um
alpha frequencies because these are
though basically if you look at like the
scope of what could be synchronized it's
this big swaths of posterior cortices
um so about eight to twelve times a
second you can generate these metastable
states where the neurons are all um
basically
more aligned in their activity and so um
i think pascal freeze we call this
communication through coherence there
you can actually
get integration and message passing and
so i'm claiming that this is entailing
basically
some joint marginal um
of
the sensorium
the engagement with the world um or
potentially a maximum a posterior or a
estimate thereof i don't know which
um
but
the
and part of the relation though um is
um
i'm thinking that this this would be
like maybe the first inner loop type
process that you might get
and
in terms of its relation to the coupling
of the world
um it might have certain special
properties
in terms of
um so i have this kind of weird idea
that by the time you get
to um like the pecunius i mentioned
these poster medial cortices um
that you're going to get these ensemble
activity of
neural ensembles normal populations
that would have a kind of chronotopic or
um
consistent
time-varying relationship of the
neuronal ensembles evolving and what's
happening in the world on the organismic
scale
um so it would be like if you know i'm
moving my hand like this it's going
below my above my eyes and there might
be some mapping now into the ensemble
activity which is then changing
roughly at that time scale and you can
detect this um
what it would partially do to bring it
together um into this like cartesian
theateresque thing
would be is this would um
i i'm i suspect it's potentially not
even um there's some sort of not just
chronotopic in terms of like a
correspondence of time there might even
be kind of
quasi-topographic euclidean properties
of it in terms of the ability of for
instance what's in the mind's eye to
actually couple the oculomotor system
which itself is going to have a kind of
coherent topography
um but
i guess the idea is that
um
you're gonna
the idea would be that the
inner
that
these
so i'm basically thinking of
consciousness as discrete updating of
the generative model
which
at eight to twelve times a second in
terms of phenomenal consciousness
and that
these discrete updates if you look at
them they're actually inner they're
divorced and so
there's there's not a direct mapping by
the time that these functional cycles
achieve closure
and so i don't know if this
is consistent or not with or uh with
london carl's uh
argument
so the 8 to 12 part seems like that's an
implementation specific detail right
because that's related to r
so it could be totally important for us
but it may not be a general feature
right now let's look at this
equation set
um
we're thinking about this intrinsic
extrinsic information approach and it's
saying it's saying the free energy of
the paulus of the now it's a little
confusing because pi is used to mean
policy in almost all situations but here
i think pi is actually comprising
blanket states and internal states so
it's a slightly different pi variable we
could get that clarified but the point
is that um the system
is going to be acting as if it's
minimizing the difference between
accuracy and complexity now in the case
of let's call it a one-to-one system
like whether it's a double pendulum
which is a chaotic system it's simple
but it's chaotic or it's a hurricane
with turbulence and reynolds numbers
if it's a one-to-one system it's not
acting as if it's
co-optimizing this trade-off of accuracy
and complexity even if you said well the
hurricane is like a model of its
environment it's just it's actually it's
a perfect model it's not minimizing the
complexity at all
just
not making an absolute claim just saying
on the other hand
if you take the intentional stance and
you're thinking about an agent and that
agent is acting as if
it is minimizing the difference between
uh
accuracy and complexity
that means that its extrinsic
information manifold is rich according
to this lz complexity metric
so when they're the same there's no
delta it just is that system so it's
almost like when you have a total state
space representation and the mapping
there's actually not that much more you
need to express you say well yeah the
chatbot said i'm conscious and i love
the beatles but that's because that's
what was preloaded so when you have the
full and that's actually why the neural
reductionist
direction i believe is ultimately
fallacious because let's just say you
had every atom in the brain then what
are we conscious or not but people are
acting like just a few more measurements
or a couple more eegs now
on the other hand when we think about
separating the internal and the external
information geometry if we find systems
that have a big delta they're acting
really really as if they're minimizing
accuracy minus complexity
and that extrinsic information manifold
we could say whether it is lz or another
type of complexity but that
extrinsic manifold is complex
like a human might get a tweet every
hour and then engage in some like super
interesting behavior that would be a big
divergence
between the intrinsic and the extrinsic
manifold
and the extrinsic behavior
would be difficult to compress with
respect to the inputs
so that might lend it a higher
complexity so there's sort of two things
there's um how much does it look like
it's minimizing its free energy
according to this structure
and then
is the extrinsic information manifold
complex and then what are the measures
of complexity
i know that's
a bunch of random stuff i'm trying to
trace the argument of the paper because
these might be the kinds of measurements
or comparators even relative
measurements or ratios that help us
understand um adam
hmm
so
i guess the
it's the first speak to like you get
what you're saying about like the
generalization and to not get like too
bogged down by the specifics of how it
might be realized within like for
instance the mammalian nervous system i
think that's really important in that
would
don't want to do that um
the
i think some of the principles um would
general like they would generalize
um and so
for me the um
i'm wondering whether actually in terms
of this
closure with respect to action
perception cycles
but actually
this is potentially uh double
the frequency or um
uh
it's you're nesting actually two quail
states within
a
broader
envelope a functional cycle that closed
that closes on a slower time scale
um and so for the brain this would be
something like theta potentially
orchestrated by something like the
campbell system which might be doing
this kind of comparator operation as a
kind of like contrastive energy based
learning but this would be like a more
general thing what you might need to be
doing is
comparing things
and um
like for the organism to uh
adaptively navigate the world and
generate a causal model
um
it might be um
that you have this more extended
generative passage level unfolding and
then within there you're forming other
nest densities or harmonics at the other
time skills that you can then use these
as objects which you then compare
between and put in relation to each
other and so any system
um i'm thinking you would have like
potentially nested markov blankets where
some of them would correspond to like
the system as a whole and its engagement
with the world where this is its own
best model and it's just this it's just
the whole it's a perfect mapping
with
um
like it's the
the hurricane or the whirlpool example
but then uh
you're then
getting
basically on as you move inwards or
outwards
you're getting these other
nest densities forming on different time
scales which are then encompassing
their markov blankets encompass the
other ones and some of these i think we
really should be thinking of these like
in terms of virtual machines you can't
point to at any given point and say aha
there you are and it might actually
extend not even within the arctic
not within the system it would be
within in between it would be relational
out into the world
um
and
i'm personally suspecting that there's
this like within like this onion of
nested markov blankets some of them call
it corresponding
to
different
uh uh some of them corresponding virtual
machines some of them corresponding to
the world as its own best model or the
world as model um uh that there might be
a point where it's like aha there there
you are i'm personally thinking
this is for the mammalian brain it's at
the alpha frequency but it it would just
be at that and so
i guess the one more thing would be um
in terms of the difference between
simulation and emulation
i actually think in in the figure that
wandra showed where he had the um
description of the von neumann
architecture and then you had this
memory register with the terms from
active inference
um
i think that i i think that mixed
scientology
um
is revealing and
it could potentially
um mislead
and that i'm wondering whether by the
time we've committed ourselves to having
these kinds of active sensory and
blanket states that you can
put into that memory register of the von
neumann architecture
we actually ought to be core screening
differently and we shouldn't be thinking
of the vinyl in architecture anymore
it's actually
um
i don't i don't know if you can actually
do brilliant analysis on that i think
it's like it might break the rules of
causal inference
i totally agree with that i think
whether it's lambda calculus or some
other algorithmic description
the current implementations of computers
are only one way and so if we mistake
the map for the territory or the
specific for the general then we're
going to be like well it's the ram and
then this channel you know if you legion
the ram it doesn't have short-term
memory doesn't that sound like these
computationalist reductionist
researchers because they are working um
sort of not clearly whether it's general
specific brain or computer and then the
quote that that reminded me of it's by
john muir the uh californian forest
lover he wrote
i only went out for a walk and finally
concluded to stay out till sundown for
going out i found was really going in
so it's like i went out for a walk it's
action planning and finally concluded to
stay out till sundown deep temporal
inference
for going out i was really going in
because when he was in the niche
acting and inferring
he was
being himself and so it really captures
like a lot of these dimensions
that we're
getting at and then also i'll raise a
question from um from cambridge breath
in the chat and it's related to what you
said about the nested systems adam
cambridge writes
can we have a non-metacognitive
conscious entity so to speak or our
consciousness and metacognition
inseparable
so we're we've used this idea of like
self-reflexive autopoetic autonomic it's
come up a ton of times
are those one and the same to be aware
conscious and recursive
or might there be some differentiating
wedge somewhere
[Music]
i mean um
i guess it depends like what we mean by
metacognition so if we're talking about
a very minimal metacognition i think
would be necessary
in terms of um
in a way i think you might be able to
think of like precision weighting as a
kind of minimal metacognition
and um and even like on what levels are
you doing your precision weighting but
this might be essential because you
can't do good inference
uh without it like
for it to be based it's this combination
of precision weighted probabilities
that's what gives it its power is
weighing things by their relative
reliability or part of what does that
like the ability to like iteratively
refine
um by leveraging your priors but
the
and so we're going to need at least
precision waiting to have probably any
kind of coherent world modeling whether
it's exactly bayesian or not um you know
but
it's got to be bayesian-ish enough i
think in order for there to be coherence
um you need to be able to take the
reliability of information and so
these precision estimations could be for
instance entailed
on many different levels they might be
for instance
entailed
mammalian so they might be just emerging
and distributed um through this like
game of free energy minimization taking
place among all these distributed
coupling elements but there might even
be also like centralized control
structures which help to give you
additional levels of precision weighting
things like
singular cortices potentially or um the
pulvinar and like um uh
that might the thalamus part of what
might make that so essential for humans
would be its persituating and you might
see in a variety of systems there might
be like even like within a cell i don't
know but there could be like you need
some sort of like centralized
integration structures for this more
global precision waiting to occur
not sure
but
in terms of like
just metacognition
bring it to the frist in
formalisms or formulisms like what
what would you say that idea connects to
when we're thinking about
how it was
formulated in the paper
you know to grow
to ground the conversation for listeners
and for ourselves like when we when we
ground it in the formalisms then we can
say well i don't think the formalism is
trying to describe the right thing or i
don't think it correctly describes what
we're agreed upon is the correct thing
um
and a lot of times it's easy to invoke
these formal frameworks but then never
clarify what our mapping is between like
okay there's a kinetic a path
independent and a path dependent term
sounds like kind of relevant but then
i'm not exactly sure that it's going to
transmute into qualia and that's like
that gap that we want to be sort of
hammering at again and again
i mean
in terms of actually thoroughgoingly
connecting back to the formalism uh you
got the wrong guy
but um
and
i i think though this would be at least
i think actually consider consistent
with like mark some's perspective also
for him uh consciousness is inherently
metacognitive and he is relating it to
precision waiting but in terms of
exactly with this more um in terms of
markovian modelism that i don't know um
how to describe that well i guess i had
one more thing in terms of like the way
i'm thinking about it which would be um
i personally uh
think that um
you can have like in contrast to like a
higher order thought type theory
that you actually so there's some
theories which for instance try to
collapse these different senses of
consciousness and they would reject for
instance potentially the difference
between phenomenal and access
consciousness or and they would say you
do need
this um
uh
you you do need these high-level
features for there to be anything at all
that um
and
i personally um if it depends on the
richness of what we mean by
metacognition so if we're saying
precision waiting then i say yes
if we're saying though things like um
autonoesis or like reflective
self-consciousness then i say probably
not we you don't need that i think there
could be something that it's like and
you could be generating qualia and these
could just
pop up there was something that it's
like as they were being as they were
emerging
and then
they go away as soon as they were there
and you weren't able to reflect on them
you weren't able to have um to compare
them potentially and you even less so
we're able to contextualize them with
relation to yourself and time in a rich
sense i think that's quite possible
um
so i don't think
you need like the more rich kinds of
metacognition to have consciousness in
terms of the appearance of the world
for the appearance of the world to be
like our appearance of the world than
you do but in terms of just the
appearance of any kind of world any kind
of what it is like this or what it feels
like this i don't think you you need
that
i i really love that connection it's
like there's the what it's
to be like whatever it is
but then the way that we actually
experience or any given individual
experiences it is so cultural it can
really never be
disentangled for example people will
tell you just yeah there's x y z it's
three axes and they're orthogonal at 90
degrees
except if you grew up studying
synergetics and buckminster fuller then
there's four spatial dimensions and the
orthogonal angles are 60 degrees so is
it really a fact of the world that it's
xyz or is that just something that's
culturally reified in the way people
talk about the world and how they
measure and how they communicate and so
it's always like this question about
what are the general attributes but you
never
observe the the genus the general you
always observe the species the specific
and so we are in a little bit of a
triple bind because we don't know what
consciousness is how to measure it or
what the observables are per se
and it's sort of like it's a catch 33
you have to solve them all in one
approach
because if you're observing something
and you're like oh it's all about the
eeg and you're going way down the rabbit
hole with a four-year transform i mean
who's to say that might be just actually
going down the wrong path
or it might be a very valuable piece of
information or it is reducing our
uncertainty about something but it may
or may not be related to the general
question it might be related like yes it
turns out that this wavelength is a
differentiator of whether someone is
going to experience pain or remember
pain
during surgery it's so important because
we don't want to
have people who are suffering
unnecessarily but then again is that the
general answer to consciousness um
interesting questions and then also to
show wanja's 2020 paper 7-eleven 2020
with these different ways
that consciousness
behavior and information could be linked
and then i had a little qualia maybe
consciousness is qualia or like you know
what if there's a thought without a
thinker or a thinker without a thought
or there's all these different options
and um
it's also just
it's a space where there's a lot of
possible perspectives in the scientific
literature in the neuroscientific
literature of the last say 200 years
it's only one facet of a really
nuanced story of humans understanding
their local world so it's just really
awesome and um we'll have just time for
a couple more thoughts and questions but
yes adam and then dave if you'd like to
add anything feel free
you know i don't cure you for some
reason adam but you're not oh yeah
personally
i personally like making uh
consciousness synonymous with qualia and
that's like the um
that's the iit stance
but um in terms of uh
what you were saying with respect to um
different types of senses of space
i was just and then in general what
you're like pointing out in general is
like
trying to find non-question begging uses
of terminology and claims
um
like
so for instance like within like my own
thinking i talk about spatial temporal
and causal coherence but at which level
and i actually there's a little bit of
an ambiguity there in my thinking that
like it's actually i think it's showing
up and entering at every scale but in
different ways so for instance you could
think of a certain um
just
entailed and for instance having a
hierarchical um predictive memory system
just having something like a heartfelt
structure like cortex you might have
itself some element of spatial and
temporal coherence built in just there
via things like
at the initial levels having a
topographic mapping to the world and
then preserving that to some degree and
maybe reintroducing it again later but
this idea of like some degree of
preserving of space
time being preserved by some sort of
coupling and then some sort of uh
homomorphism and maybe some sort of
increasing temporal depth of
nested
causes that unfold in different time
scales via
a hierarchy where the deep levels are
things that are unfolding more slowly so
you're getting some time just there
um and cause you might even think of
something like spike timing dependent
plasticity where you wire up the system
based on um the predictive information
coming in the right order as being like
a kind of protocol prior since like
causes ought to proceed effects
however that's a different sense than
like for instance
a richer sense that might be important
for the appearance of a world of space
time and cause where it would come in
for instance in terms of
potentially something that's more
constructed it's like what type of space
are we dealing with if you're in like
this buckminster fuller world um that
might be a very different sense of space
it might not be xyz
and there might be a different sense of
time for you and a different sense of
cause by the time we get to
phenomenalities or rather i think it is
a different sense
um
and
then there might be yet another sense in
terms of like the inter-subjective and
the higher like the more narrative
meaning-making of space-time and cause
where it's like the metaphors we use
about space and time and the ways we
construct these like linguistically and
like these higher order semantics and
then these by couple as priors for each
other in all sorts of interesting ways
so um there's like ambiguity there or
like there's um and i guess to kind of
come back to
this idea of like so i've been thinking
that um
uh you couldn't think of like within
global neural workspace theory um
that i kind of generalize it a bit and
that i treat the workspace as not just
this like fronto parietal network i
would consider it to be a type of
workspace and potentially a type of
virtual machine workspace
of um uh i think that uh where it's
involving these action perception cycles
being closed
um like these kind of fictive
imaginative action perception cycles
or real ones but
um you could also think of let's say
you're just having like the estimates of
the sensorium like you're getting these
like
these compo these nest densities or
harmonic self-organizing harmonic modes
like
if you're getting big swaps of cortex
all engaging in marginal messaging all
communicating their beliefs together to
create a joint estimate of the
engagement of the system with its world
it may not involve the whole system but
if it's big enough i still consider that
to be kind of like consistent with a
global workspace it's big it's allowing
multiple things to kind of do this
ensemble slash federated learning and
inference creating the synergy getting a
hole that squared in someone's parts
making information more globally
available or creating like fame in the
brain as then then called it and so i'd
say like that's still very that's a
workspace it's a sort of iterated
bayesian model selection
but like within but what do we mean by
workspace
and how much when we say workspace
at some levels do we mean spatial itself
is it like is the workspace itself a
kind of space
and but now to what degree is it a
constructed space and what kind of
constructed space
ah
and global oh well of course i don't
mean like the globe global i mean like
you know something else it when things
are universal global basic there's so
many adjectives that
help people share
memes and ideas
but really don't always reduce
uncertainty about what's being discussed
because they're being used in explicitly
a
non-helpful way
and so it's um
it's always a challenge to parse out and
translate sometimes even on the fly
which
types of usage are actually like okay
attention is actually supposedly about
the thing we're talking about here but
global okay it's a totally different
usage and there's a bunch of times when
the same sentence you have words that
are like really drawn from different
name spaces they're drawn from quite
different um views yeah adam and then
dave if you ever want to you know add
anything go ahead raise your hand but go
ahead adam just a quick thought i was
just like in general
i think part of it is like
we need to use more words and not argue
so much about like what words mean is if
like we're receiving them from plato's
philosopher king they came on to us on
highs this ideal form rather like words
as tools and making them useful tools
and like you know we're going to want to
probably stick as much as we can to like
common or folk like usage and like folk
psychology as much as we can
but sometimes we won't but
basically trying to find the one that
does
the least
uh
that captures the senses of use that we
tend to use
um as much as we can
but also
uh
well while sometimes pushing back on
like our common understandings
um
but you know
i think along this though using like
more words like
phenomenal consciousness access
consciousness maybe we want to break
those down further um you know uh
there's a limit to what we can do before
the tools become like not serviceable in
our hands but i think
we definitely should be using more than
like i think people are tending to
expect like this one-to-one mapping
of word to the relevant natural kinds
and i i think that's a problem i think
that's uh
i think we should at least two words
maybe as many as three
more than that i think is a problem um
but i'd say two words we would do so
much better for always using
two
thanks adam um dave
yeah the uh
you mentioned plato uh the latest
edition of uh
sean carroll's mindscape uh the the
guest is um says there's two scholars in
china who are explicit and proud
followers of leo strauss and they have
followed his method and read all the
works of plato
each one of which proves that xi jinping
is the perfect leader and the the world
that he rules is the best of all
possible worlds
and could you please send me an
invitation to the uh markovian monism
talk please
thanks thanks for the uh statements and
claims and questions yes so
um
yeah yeah yeah go away
so in terms of like one concrete debate
and like consciousness studies so for
instance um it seems like a lot of the
dispute between like global neural
workspace theory and angry information
theory could be resolvable and
them just talking about consciousness in
different senses and if we add
additional words this will become clear
so instead of like
fighting
engaging this like death match if the
word will be this there can be only one
it would be like okay so maybe
iit is focusing on phenomenality and
maybe um
gnwt is focusing on access
and when iit says that the physical and
potentially computational substrates of
consciousness are tend to be
corresponding to posterior hot zone they
might be largely correct and when gnwt
says it's actually
a more broadly distributed frontal
parietal lexus they might be correct
also
but in one case they're talking more
about phenomenal consciousness in one
case you're talking more about access
consciousness and so like there's this
huge like adversarial collaboration
happening but actually i'm worried that
it's all in the wrong terms assuming
that like one framework will be the
victor
when actually it should be
not that you're all right in like a like
a wash that way but for the like sure
let's go for a minimal unifying model it
won't just sink but there might be like
this minimally model might take in
both parties and they might be happy i i
t people might be happy gmwt people
might be happy if we just use more words
yep
um okay no one has to be wrong
you might be but no one has to be wrong
i'll give a take on it dave though
yeah maybe some of the folks to
helpfully
remind us that the map is not the
territory should just go back and read
science insanity
sounds good and and what i kind of got
out of there with consciousness and this
is i guess hopefully an approach we're
enacting and carrying through is
how are we going to share the tools
maybe statistical parametric mapping spm
toolkit maybe the developing active
inference toolkit how are we going to
share the tools and align on action
that is within everyone's affordance um
within everyone's niche
rather than
zero in on the eternal essential and
truly fundamental differences in our
perspectives and contexts um you're not
gonna get people to agree on what a
pizza is you're not gonna get people to
agree on what culture is and so we're
way way way past physical objects here
and so
how are we going to have a a story and
an approach field where we can come
together and reduce our uncertainty
about like our physiology and our
emotional responses which are part of
our physiology
and focus on potentially the before the
decimal point shared reality rather than
the after the decimal point divergences
in the seventh adjective or the list
ordering adam
i think that what you're saying actually
in some ways that's the essence of
like the way to proceed in that like i
feel like no one has to be wrong because
we all have to be wrong all the time
like all you know all models all
metaphors are wrong some of them are
useful and we're going for maximal use
and it's not saying that like this is a
post-modern wish wash and anything goes
but there's going to be some uses of
terminology that are more or less
helpful for getting at basically
different grips on the latent world
and um
for which all of our words are mere
approximations um there is a world there
are better and worse ways to describe it
but these better and worse ways of
describing it there's always an interest
and it's our interests
and so i think bringing like basically
our values back into the picture
hopefully our shared values and this
being
that's how we have to proceed i i
totally agree i think that um the the
movement that is reflected by people
calling for transparency or
interpretability or reproducibility in
machine learning let's say it reflects a
desire to be able to really
weave together
who is being served and who's being
influenced and our values with technical
details
and so
it's just
it's been special and been really
interesting to think about how something
that
you know you could
call out some
technical component but it provides a
starting place
for actually fully intertwining our
values in and um yeah it's gonna be a
tightrope to walk between
everyone's correct no one's correct
everyone is neither correct nor
uncorrect or everyone's involved in a
process of correction how are we gonna
move from the essentialist claims like
who's right and who's not or which
subcomponent of myself are correct or
not
to a broader story of
whatever it ends up being in different
people's perspective and there wouldn't
be any sequence of words
english or otherwise from any speaker
that is gonna end up
being the end-all because they're just
it's like the finger in the moon you're
pointing at the moon
you're not pointing to the spot at the
tip of your finger it's something far
far away
and something aspirational so that's how
the words are
and especially with the consciousness
you know again even with the food
like i would say that
food could be an aspirational or an
asymptotic or a platonic thing but then
this is like
quite
wrapped up in our own experience of
course so
thanks so much to the two of you guys
any few um
any last thoughts or just what does this
excite you
um about
moving forward
or what would be some next thoughts or
just imagine some archetype of some
listener or viewer and what would you
suggest to them ask them
i mean for me
and like it's both like fundamental the
question like the just
you know
what is consciousness what is life who
who am i what what what's going on like
it's it it's of a like an existential
meaningful character these conversations
but i also think um
basically i'm hoping that we're getting
close to
um bringing back in
consciousness uh in a meaningful way
into science
um
kind of overcoming
basically a kind of behaviorist legacy
where it kind of made sense to make some
things uh somewhat taboo for a time
because we didn't feel like we had
purchase but then that taboo became
maybe stifling and tyrannical i don't
know if we've completely shrugged it off
yet but there's a sense where
um
by we try to be as precise as we can we
contextualize you know what are our
value commitments what is the specific
way in which we're using terminology in
this case trying to be as precise as we
can
i think we might be at a point where we
can start to
bring things like consciousness back in
without having to be embarrassed about
it and i think this embarrassment
actually did something really bad which
basically took your experience
and removed it out of the scientific
discourse and basically made it unreal
and i think we're going to discover not
only was this
bad for us
personally interpersonally but it was
bad for us scientifically because i
actually suspect that consciousness is
the maximally
important
informational and energetic object
in at least our minds
and that this we basically hid
the main story we made taboo telling the
main story
and
that we made taboo different things that
like part of the reason we didn't have
purchase was that it was we were being
imprecise it was hard but part of it was
we made taboo the things we would need
to make purchase so phenomenology we
made experience taboo and then we
wondered why it was so hard to make
purchase unconsciousness no one was
talking about embodiment and then we're
like hmm why aren't i able to
cross-explanatory gaps with a giant
flailing leap
and that unfortunately in a historical
in a cultural context it led to divide
and conquer of academia it led to the
bifurcation of
non-academic experience with academic
research it led to disciplinary
um unneeded friction i i really agree
with that um
it's like it was a scientific error to
think that the finger was pointing at
the tip of the finger and say well
because we don't know exactly the detail
we're going to like not just
you know write a review paper and then
go back to our lab we're going to go on
stage and we're going to tell people
that they're zombies we're going to tell
people that they're robots or we're
going to tell them this is how the brain
generates consciousness and so that's
why i'm always excited to hear about new
research in the field but
i
would hope that kind of like coffee and
cream like it would always be
blended
with a recognition that it's an open
question it's an experienced
um
it's something we're experiencing
and so we're not just gonna cut it and
try it leave on stage 15 minute talk
it's done
because think about how many thousands
of those lectures have been delivered
in the last hundred years from
when you know today's nurse oh that was
too early but they were just being
enthusiastic to today and that's tens of
thousands of people or however many
people who got um pushed in a different
direction
because um using legacy credentials they
were told their experience was not
concordant with science which is really
something that's hard to estimate the
impact of
one more thing would be
i want i'm also open to there might be
some uh things that might be cut and dry
and i don't know so for instance one of
them could be at questions like it's
possible
that first like depending on how which
senses of consciousness we mean
that there might be um cut and dry
versus more graded distinctions we
should be looking for so it could be or
could not be the case that basic
phenomenality is cut and dry we don't
know um i have flossed this but one
thing would then kind of later coming in
this might have relevance now for things
like animal rights and this might have
relevance going forward for things like
the future of ai
maybe
can we create artificial general
intelligence and then when if and when
we do if we survive long enough and if
we're smart enough will these be um
morally relevant agents or will they be
part of our moral communities
and so
um
whether things are graded or not it
could end up being crucial there might
be some cases where it's like aha once
we nail down our use of words based on
our interests and we have like this many
qualifiers we feel like okay this is the
optimal grip on like
numeral space whatever this is like the
optimal grip on the world on on light in
space and you say okay
cut and dry
but it might not be but this this might
be the most important questions
ultimately that we can ever ask
and here's where i think active
inference might speak to it dave then if
you want to anything or not is here's
where it's cut and dry
the observables sense and action and so
we can be clear about what we're cut and
dry outside here's how um
using um the theory of information
processing we're talking about auditory
processing but then to go that next
level of emotional salience and say and
this is why you hear this when this
happens
that's the part where it can be
clarified that there's things that are
um basically cut and dry models
but those are cut and dry because
they've been partitioned from a broader
field
of discussion
not because one day the cut and dry is
going to be everything it's actually
like everything isn't that way and we've
made these islands of stability
um that are are despite that not like
the other way around so
um
dave any last comments
thanks so much this was really um really
awesome conversation as always
appreciate the live participants and the
those in the live chat and watching
later this is it for actually the first
quarter of 2021
for active stream pretty fun next week
we're going to be having our quarterly
round table so if anybody wants to make
like a three to five minute video for
this one or a future round table they're
welcome to do that
then
um
we're gonna be having these upcoming
events so it's gonna be just
on with the show and the learning and
doing and participating so thanks
everyone and see you later
you